Big O notation is very useful because we can use it to concentrate
just on the fastest growing part of the function and even without all the involved constants.
I now want to show you a few examples to make this more concrete.
So 3n+1 for example would be contained in O(n) because we do not care about the +1
and 3n grows at the same rate.
It does grow at least as fast as n.
The function 18n²-50 would be contained in O(n²) because again n² here is the fastest growing term.
We do not care the minus 50 and we don't care about the constants.
Now very similarly here, if you have 2ⁿ+30n⁶+123 that would be in O(2ⁿ).
We do not care about the constant and those two terms here, they both depend on n but
2ⁿ outgrows the 30n⁶ and since we add those two terms here, 2ⁿ is really just the fastest growing part.
Now if we don't add those two parts here but for example we multiply 2ⁿn²,
we need to include that into the O notation because just having 2ⁿ
that grows slower than 2ⁿn².
We just have 2ⁿ here. That statement would not be true because 2ⁿ grows slower than 2ⁿ n² .
So what about a statement like 3n+1 is contained in O of n² because n² really grows at least as fast as n.
This one must also be true and it is true the only thing it would unusual to write this
because usually we're trying to state this bound here as tight as possible.
Similar down here, you could also say that 18n² -50 is contained in O of to the n³
but again this would be unusual to write because if we have a tighter bound that we can state,
we would state this part over here.
Enough with the examples, I'm going to let you figure out the rest as our next quiz.